foreign
I claim to be from San Pedro California
um I've lived
Compton Long Beach watch uh all over the
place
so tell me about your family
I have my well I had my mother she was
the only family member that I knew
she was a severe alcoholic
um
she has something called DTS that I
didn't know about uh I didn't learn
about until I was 37.
so um
she used to let me do things to me when
I was young so she could get copper
bottle before two o'clock before the
storage and their bars closed
and I hated it for a long time but then
like I said once I learned that she had
DTS I kind of understood a little bit
better I mean they didn't excuse what
she did but I'm still a little bit
better
she's been gone now about
I don't know about
eight years I don't even actually
remember when she died I just know I
couldn't see it I couldn't watch her die
so
yeah excuse me my father um
with a truck driver
I know that he looked like um
um what's his name
um
little gossip Junior
he was a truck driver from Texas that's
all I know I met him once when I was 12.
and I stabbed him in the shoulder blade
because he slapped my mama
and I haven't seen him since then
how'd you describe your childhood in
general I've never had a childhood
never had one
you went to high school uh yeah I
dropped out in the seventh grade though
uh I was smoking dope I started smoking
hot cocaine when I was 11.
today's my birthday so I'm 51. happy
birthday thank you
um I started smoking up when I was 11.
came down here when I was 19.
um been down here 31 years like I said
today's my birthday I'm 51 so I've been
down here 31 years out of those 51. yeah
let's get her over yeah skidwell
homeless uh we're even sing Where have
you stayed all over
um but I've never had really had my own
tent I mean we had like a tent three
tenths out of 31 years I've been down
here
and I never went rooms so
um then one time I rented a room I
rented out to see so and uh some man I
don't know whether he jumped out the
window or got thrown out the window but
um he landed right there on top of the
sea sign where my window was
and uh I've never I've never in a room
since
yeah being a woman on schedule has got
to be Rush man rough
look at this
[ __ ] what is that
[ __ ] bruises look a man thinking I'm
saying that they can put their hands on
women like I don't understand like men
have a manhood right
women have a Womanhood right
I mean
some men are used against pimping women
or intimidating women out of to do
whatever they want uh whatever some
menus drugs as a mother as a [ __ ]
bait um
I don't know what the issues are with
these men out here today but it's not
okay to keep putting their hands on me
that's all I know
I've had six fractured ribs in the last
two years I've been having 31 but then
last two years I've never had a broken
bone in my body
two years I've had six fractured ribs
the last way to explain
dislocated kneecap
20 Staples in my elbow
um broken finger over 10 concussions
um I've been asphyxiated I've had my
head shoved through the back windshield
of a car
um just
crazy it's just crazy I don't know what
it is
um
I know back in the days when I was
younger my whole boy just respect me
because I didn't put myself out there
like that I didn't you know I wasn't a
hoe I wanted a strawberry or whatever
you want to call it you know I didn't do
any and everything for dope and I smoke
dope but I'm just not willing to do any
and everything for it and I needed to
function you know what I mean so it
makes it kind of difficult when you run
into
all you run into is people that want to
[ __ ] suck for some [ __ ] dope
you know I'm saying so I'm just not
gonna be able to do it you know would
you make money oh
well back in days I'm a whole lot cuter
than this
um most of the time I just had to sit
around sit around people and it would
give me money or I learned how to uh
chop up drugs and I guess you get paid
to do that because I did it very well
um sometimes if I you know got in
company somebody that just wouldn't stop
talking about wanting to have sex uh and
they were what we call a market whatever
I don't know I would buy their dope for
them and turn around and and give them
half of it and then when they want to
buy some more turn around the other half
of it but I mean when I was younger like
when I was 11 12 13 you know stuff like
14 and [ __ ] like that I would jump in
the cars and act like I was gonna do
something
uh with the person for twenty dollars as
soon as they put that twenty dollars in
my hand I would jump out the car it
didn't matter how fast it was moving I
would get you know
concrete burn or whatever whatever the
case may be but it didn't matter because
I'm on my way to the medicine man so
cocaine was made for pain
they just Twisted it along with
everything else your drug is cracked now
huh your drug is cracked yeah there's a
difference between rock cocaine and
crack rock
uh my drug choice is rock cocaine
but um crack gets in you know thrown in
there every now and then and it's not a
good look
at all
so do you have kids yeah
um I have two girls
one is 31.
and the other 25.
um
I got raped by three gang members when I
was eight months pregnant with my oldest
in San Pedro California and um
I remember the evidence coming to take
you to the hospital because I had her in
the middle of the street after I got
raped and they came and took us to the
hospital and um
I was cussing God out you know what I'm
saying tell him his name spelled
backwards was dog and I hated him and
this and that but then something came up
with me and I said if he gave me a name
to have some type of holy significance
toward him to name my daughter then I
believe that he was willing you know
what I'm saying he blessed me to see her
when he saw fit again
and so the nurse came in there and asked
me what my daughter's name was and I
told her she prayer so
s-h-a-p-r-a-y-i-a supreya and then after
that um this lady came in my room she
was like a Medea type lady you know
everybody's mom you know and she told me
baby God told me that you having
problems um you need somebody to take
care of your daughter
she said my name is Miss Emma and I live
in Inglewood and I'd be happy to take
care of your baby until you get better
and you could come get her you know when
you when you when you all right with God
right
so that's that's what happened to my
daughter so after that I left the
hospital got on the RTD
Destination Unknown and just rolled and
rode the road and ended up out here
August 7 1991 to 2 30 a.m right there in
front of the Ford hotels and I've been
down here ever since
I was just turning 20 just 19. yeah
31 of my 31 years of my life going
so fast
um
then I have a uh my youngest daughter's
25 her dad was from down here
um she must get well baby she went to
the Navy and got raped uh while underage
drinking
so I'm gonna sue the Navy I'm going to
sue the United States Navy
I have a few lawsuits that you know God
is blessing me with
you know if you feel like life is unfair
uh yeah I do I feel like life owes me
something
and it does as far as I'm concerned all
the hell that I've been through I've
never had a childhood like I said I've
been using dope since I was 11.
um my body has been through so freaking
much man it's like I'm lucky to be alive
I'm lucky to [ __ ] be here holding a
conversation with you I'm lucky you know
I've been dead down here five times by
my own hand
and uh so if it was meant for me to die
I'll stay dead you know so I'm not
scared to die
um it's just down here is not the same
anymore you know you got people coming
from all over the world coming down here
trying to make this their you know their
their spot their their neighborhood
their whatever you know and it's not
that to me that's not okay
you know because I'm still putting I'm
still putting in work you know I'm
saying still
paying my dues to be here and for
somebody that's from somewhere else to
come and tell me what I can't can't do
and I'm not messing with you I'm not
disrespecting you I'm not you know I'm
not [ __ ] with you but you want to
come [ __ ] with me [ __ ] with me
[ __ ] with me and to me that's not
okay and I'm not I'm really angry you
know I'm actually homicidal suicidal now
because I'm tired of being putting their
hands on me I really want to you know
it's not okay it's not okay
everybody can say what they want to say
but then when I get to talking
I got to shut up or I gotta move or
somebody gonna beat me up but
um you know so that's what I'm at work
with right now that and finally getting
my own place for the first time in my
life
um it's a little studio and it's not
where I want to be but I'm grateful you
know I mean rough over your head makes a
big difference right I'm sorry having a
roof over your head can make a big
difference right a really big difference
you know so that's why I say I'm
grateful you know I don't have to
tolerate being put out I wrote a hell of
a poem I wish I would have brought it
with me I really did I try to say um
remember as much as I can but I called
it no more right
no more lies
no more pain
no more being put out of someone else's
spot to be stuck out in the rain
No More Drama
no more strife
no more selling for less than I deserve
because I deserve more in my life
no more stress No More Tears
no more living to regret what I consider
31 Wasted Years
normal being strong from being beat by
men who knew they were wrong
no more misery no more regret no more
reliving the things that I will never
forget
no more sacrificing being willing to
literally give someone else my shirt
no more scrubbing my body
of three decades of skidwell dirt
No More Tears no more crying no more
feeling like I'm better off dying
no more dealing with other people and
their demons trying to convince him that
it's okay
no more struggling to keep from getting
in my own way
no more caring for people for them I'm
here to serve
[ __ ] that after 31 years I'm living the
life that I deserve
and my love of the place right now
because I have so much going on in my
life that
I'm tired my body's just tired you know
I got a lot to do and I keep
procrastinating and these are blessings
that'll come in my way and I don't have
to do it myself I have a lot of money
out there in the hemisphere
you know I mean because God has blessed
me like I'm very intelligent I'm gifted
I'm I got skills you know um
and I'll be trying to share it with
other people but they're going to have
to try to share with them the more they
hate me for it I don't understand where
that comes from either
you know not to mention I'm an empath
you know so it's hard my life has really
been [ __ ] hard and I'm really [ __ ]
tired I just want to be happy and I want
to die in Amsterdam
I want to die in Amsterdam
why Amsterdam yeah I don't want to die
out here in L.A I'm scared well
I want to die in Amsterdam
that's my that's my
that's my dying wish I just want to die
in Amsterdam
what emotions do you go through living
here what emotions do you often go
through
um I have an emotional disability
so um my emotions uh controlled me
a whole lot like you know in the past
they don't control me as much as they
used to
thank God for that but um
I'm a I'm a I'm a big bag full of
emotions like every emotion a human
being can feel I feel all at one time
you know so it doesn't matter whether
it's good bad right wrong and different
every emotion a human being can feel as
a human being I feel all at one time and
it seems like all the time
that's how I can explain it I can't
explain it the other way
do you describe yourself as
self-destructive
yeah
um I used to be really self-destructive
um today I'm more like a
uh
I don't want to say like a lab rat or a
research project or some something like
that I have some things that's going on
with me that I think it would go down in
the medical journal but I can't have I
can't find anyone to sit down and really
listen to me and pay attention and and
to me and
uh realize what it is that I'm going
through
you know because
some people are they're [ __ ] crazy
they're [ __ ] off they're tripping
they'd be tweaking they're going through
you know and I get it but
um God is using me for whatever you know
what I mean I'm uh
I know
these 31 years down here haven't been in
vain I know my pain hasn't been a vein
um I know that something good is going
to come out of this
I just don't want to be in my own way I
don't want to get in my own way
you know until I stay out of my way in
other people's way but I'm just tired of
people telling me what I can and can't
do and you know disrespecting me and
putting your hands on me because then
you wonder why some people snap and just
go off and just start shooting a whole
bunch of [ __ ] you know what I
mean they wonder why
you know and I'm a woman too by myself
you know I'm just not gonna keep
tolerating it I'm just not
I'm gonna say what I want to say I have
the right to say whatever I want to say
I do I have them right to say whatever I
want to say everybody else says what
they want to say so who the [ __ ] who am
I to tell you what you can say
you know what I mean if you if I'm
feeling some type of way I'm going to
express that because if I don't I know
I'm gonna [ __ ] around and I'm Gonna Hurt
Somebody
because I'm not allowing nobody to hurt
me no more
I refuse I don't deserve it and and I'm
not going to tolerate it anymore
the man woman try to be something to
[ __ ] that you know
what are you afraid of no uh what am I
afraid of I'm afraid of dying unhappy
I'm afraid to never finding happiness
and peace in my life
I'm afraid of uh never
having to be able to have the experience
of what it is to have your own home your
own car
um
Desiring something and being able to
just be able to get it without no no no
problems you know no
ulterior motives no you know no nothing
I just want to be happy I just want to
be comfortable
you know
I want my grandson in my life
his birthday is Thursday
and I promised him I would have a place
for him to come to before his birthday
and
it took uh nine months after I got the
voucher but I mean it's something you
know it's not what I really truly wanted
but it's something he has a place to
come see me now
you know
um that's what I want
yeah that's what I want you've been in
love before have I been in love before
yes I've been in love a couple times
um
the thing about love is this
um I've had it in my life
uh
really good love
but I didn't know what I had and I
didn't know
um how deep it was
um I know for me when I'm with somebody
I'm with somebody and I'm loyal
it doesn't matter what we go through you
know unless you know that a self of
abuse you know I've suffered I've
suffered too many years uh at the hands
of being able to domestic violent
Survivor and I'm I just can't I don't
love I'm not in love with nobody or love
nobody enough for them to keep putting
their hands on me and hurting me you
know so I'd rather be by myself
you know just me me and my pet whenever
I get one
dear friends
no
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently everything
everything I mean everything
um I definitely would have been you know
that child who uh well by age anyway
that child who uh insisted on uh that
homosexual babysitter giving me some of
the dope that they were smoking because
um I was hungry or because I smoked my
last joint you know I wonder what my
life would have been like if I never had
put my mouth on a pipe
you know I remember what happened to me
since at the age of three
and um
I want to write books I want to write
books
I just I don't feel that I can
accomplish these things without cocaine
in my life
that's my only that's my only dilemma
it's like when when I use
myself medicate
I've become like I get these million
dollar making epiphanies
you know what I mean and they're they're
amazing you know what I mean and I can't
share them with nobody because they
don't give a [ __ ] or you know they think
it's like yeah pipe dreams or you know
I'm saying [ __ ] like that you know
but I know yeah
I know that I'm a good woman and I know
how to be a friend and I'm very loyal
I'm loyal to to a fault but I'm tired of
sacrificing my life and my freedom for
people that don't give a [ __ ] about me
you know I've been paid the price for
being Good Samaritan a couple times you
know what I mean and it's like damn
that's what I get that's [ __ ] up you
know so I see why some people are
isolated into themselves or some people
just don't like people I used to be a
people person but I don't like people
anymore I don't like people anymore I
don't like being around a crowd of
people because it just the scandalous
it's like they said in my soul and and
then something devil dick for whatever
it is they want you know what I mean
it's just not who I am
I'm a little I'm living in little hell
they're living in the house since I was
three years old
what's your favorite memory you know my
favorite memory
oh let me see
it's a good question
I don't know I guess the first time I
seen the Frozen waterfall I think you
asked me this question before
the first time I seen the snow that was
a beautiful memory
I don't have too many good memories
what's your biggest regret
putting a pipe in my mouth allowing
somebody to put a pipe in my mouth at a
child's age you think I might have
redirected everything I believe it would
have changed the whole course of my life
I mean getting a body tell me it
wouldn't have more than a sexual abuse
that happened
um I don't think that
um
well I don't know because that started
when I was three you know what I mean
the first time it happened and the other
[ __ ] that I've been through in my life
yeah
so while the abuse that I've had in my
life
got sexual abuse that that happened to
me when I was three years old that pain
doesn't compare to anything I've been
through and I've been through hell
you know that's another thing that I
want to do is I want to change the law
when it comes to uh [ __ ] pedophiles
I want a [ __ ] there's a
pedophile
should be should be sentenced to
automatic 25 years before they even
think about parole
you know what I'm saying for real and
then if they get out on parole and they
violate you know you know what I'm
saying
they do life without no parole uh if
[ __ ] has a prior automatic life
without parole you know so I want to
change that law they give a [ __ ] dope
dealer a [ __ ] drug addict
[ __ ] time then they do a
[ __ ] pedophile
you know let R Kelly be the example [ __ ]
your financial status
[ __ ] your [ __ ] status in the [ __ ]
world period Judge [ __ ] jury
[ __ ] police politician [ __ ]
Reverend [ __ ] bum on the street it
don't [ __ ] matter who you are
you automatically get 25 [ __ ] years
in a Penitentiary before you think about
getting out parole and then you have to
be you have to do you have to put work
in like I was I want to come up with a
[ __ ] book workbook for [ __ ]
pedophiles they have to do the whole
time they're [ __ ] they're in there or
out you know I mean it's mandatory for
them to keep continuing to do that book
over and over and over again until
either if they finally Dawns in their
head and it clicks like what the [ __ ] am
I doing this is a [ __ ] child
you know what I mean like that [ __ ]
sticks with you for the rest of your
[ __ ] life like you can really [ __ ] up
a child's life by violating him that way
there's no there's no get back from that
you know what I mean there's no
that's that's what [ __ ] up my life you
know I'd rather say that's what [ __ ]
up my life drug cocaine actually helped
me get through it
you know I'll be self-medicating all my
life the traffic this might have made
you use the pipe yeah yeah I mean it did
it did like
that's what helps me cope
from everything that's happened to me
since I was three years old I don't know
where the way to cope I really don't
I've been using dope since I was 11
years old today I'm 51.
how many years is that
40 years 40
I was smoking though for 40 years of my
[ __ ] life
I don't know no other way to function
and it's scary and then people get mad
because you're not weak enough to suck a
dick or you're not you're not weak
enough to [ __ ] let a [ __ ]
want to train on you or you're not you
know just I just want to suck your
nipples I just want you to put you know
[ __ ] all that like I don't have less
demons you know what I mean [ __ ] that
doesn't come with the territory you know
so you know my homeboys like I said back
in the day they used to respect me
because I didn't put myself out there
like that I never wanted for anything
because I didn't put myself out there
like that you know and they respected me
those were real men
these [ __ ] today I don't know
what the [ __ ] they are but they're not
mean
God I needed this so bad God assault
yahshua is amazing y'all she was amazing
thank you Lord
yeah everything happens for a reason I
I'm I'm very spiritual I'm not religious
I'm spiritual
and I believe that spirituality and
astrology uh all of that goes hand in
hand you can't have one without the
other you know what I mean because at
all
there are coincides you know and that's
um if it wasn't for that
my love for music
um music
is like
music is my other drug you know I have
to have it like I have to have it
you know um
I feel like sometimes I'm a snap
you know
um if ever I'm upset or [ __ ] going
off or [ __ ] tripping or whatever
a person that really really knows me
knows that I needed some music and I'll
be okay
you know what I mean I don't have music
before dope and I have to have dope to
cope so you know in order to function
but
as you have my music and it's like when
I can't get that it's like I feel a big
ass I feel like I want to die
you know what I mean I feel like I want
to die
because if I can't express myself no
more through pen and paper or orally you
know vocal my you know what the [ __ ] I'm
going through
there's a song about it you know there's
a song about everything that's [ __ ]
going on and been went on in life and
gonna continue to go on it's like music
is a universal language you know so
it wasn't for music a pen and paper
cocaine
um
I'd be a blizzard idiot I'd be like
I don't know I know I wouldn't be here I
know that for a fact
um I don't know what my destiny is I
don't know you know what my future may
hold
I know is that don't want it to be
downtown I don't want to die downtown I
want to die in Amsterdam like I said
everything in Amsterdam is legal
everything so mutagenix it makes you
[ __ ] hallucinated it's illegal you
know
um and it's legal because there's no
crime out there there's no crime out
there because everything is legal like
duh you know what I mean but this [ __ ]
out here I can't do it no more I'm
really scared I'm gonna kill somebody
you know and and I know if I do I'm
Justified you know so you know uh I'd
fight for a standing ground law out here
in California like they do you know like
they have in another state you know what
I mean but um
if I ever do anything to anybody I'm
justified in doing it because they've
hurt me real real bad and I'm like I'm
I'm traumatized like a [ __ ] you
know
um
and I can't stop it it's like I have
flashbacks I don't like being around
people anymore
um
um I have anxiety it's like I'm
depressed all the time it's like it's
just I go through all these different
feelings like I said all at one time if
you could put a word to that then please
do because I haven't come up with one
yet
you know and it's just
my faces was keeping me keeping me alive
my will to survive
because I'm a survivor
and I'm a strong black woman I am a
queen and I deserve to be happy because
I know how to be a friend and I know how
to love
and I'm gonna die knowing what real love
is you know and I'm with that I call my
head up high
yeah thank you so much for sharing your
story oh no problem I hope I answered
all your questions you did thank you
thank you